wir kommen zum motto wir haben uns
wieder überlegt was haben wir euch für
gemeine fragen stellen und verharmlose
frage ihr könnt selber wählen die roten
sind zum einen die grünen sind harmlos
aber nicht es ist wirklich so wir sind
ehrlich also das sagt noch nie einer
sich da vergriffen so viel ziehen wie
ihr wollt und ihr könnt sagen wir gucken
du musst ja gemein jetzt machen ende mit
dem kuscheln hier hatten wir keine lust
etwas richtiges zu lernen
nein also in der tat ist das immer schon
ein traum gewesen dass fluri leben eines
musikers till ich hatte schon angefangen
informatik zu studieren habe dann aber
das angebot des bereichs bekommen und
kauft gerade fertig mit dem abi und das
war für mich voll auf die musik als mein
traum und ich bin wirklich froh dass
zuge kommen dass ich bin auch sehr
dankbar dass ich das so machen kann ist
es für euch ein traum
wie war's ja also man kennt das ja ich
war früher auch immer gesungen imker
erstmal und dann gesangsunterricht immer
genommen klassischen gesangsunterricht
und dann irgendwann hat man mal so
vorbilder gehabt oder beziehungsweise
auch irgendwie bands die einen gefallen
aber no angels zum beispiel die da total
in war nichts heute
und dann hat man also getanzt und
gesungen und sich das eigentlich immer
schon gewünscht so auf der bühne zu
stehen
super nächste frage darf grünen ziehen
sie ist so schlimm sind die roten fragen
gar nicht es geht bin ich mal gespannt
was darauf steht ihr singt und redet
viel von freundschaft wie schafft ihr es
für eure freunde da zu sein
freunde wir sind immer also ich muss ja
von mir auch sagen wenn ich zu hause bin
dann versuche ich auf jeden fall immer
was mit meinen freunden zu machen das
ist aber auch nicht immer so leicht weil
die studieren ja auch irgendwo anders
meistens oder macht
eine ausbildung und wenn wir aber
allemal da sind dann treffen wir uns
auch und versuchen so viel zeit wie
möglich zusammen zu verbringen und wir
wozu die neuen medien natürlich auch gut
zu nutzen sind es um freundschaften zu
pflegen oder auch mal sich anzumelden
und zu sagen hey wie gehts dir
eigentlich gerade und/oder wir
telefonieren auch öfter und da muss ich
schon sagen dass wir da uns alle sehr
viel mühe gegeben also von meinem
freundeskreis dass das wir und so oft
wie möglich sehen
das freut mich natürlich auch immer
welche hause kommen und mal wieder meine
freundinnen treffen kann
nächste frage woher bekommt ihr die
inspiration folge einfühlsamen texte das
sind einfach ganz alltägliche dinge also
caro ist ja bei uns eher so der text
partner nicht eine musikalische und das
sind wirklich also geschichten von uns
die wir erlebt haben und die uns
irgendwie inspiriert haben wenn man
irgendwas hört oder liest und das ist
wirklich das können ganz alltägliche
dinge sein da gibt es auch gar kein
rezept oder regel dafür dass es wirklich
kann sein beispiel dem supermarkt und
bekommt die geschlagen die idee und
nimmt das dann gleich aufs iphone auf
und macht daraus gezogen also das ist da
gibt es kein rezept dafür aber muss
irgendwie muss man selber blut in den
genen na ja also ich glaube man dann
mehr texte als ich also sehr sehr
begabter auf jeden fall
und ich glaube dass man muss einfach
schon auch so ein bedürfnis haben auch
eine geschichte zu erzählen und
vielleicht auch die erzielen zu wollen
der erste text angefangen mit 12 9 oder
so habe ich meiner freundin zusammen ein
lied über jungs geschrieben
neun oder zehn und dann die jungs aber
so geärgert in der schule und an
angeschrieben denn irgendwie so
irgendwie fing das an mit jungs
warum sind und dann ging es weiter
ich lass das jetzt lieber ich zieh mal
wieder eine runde in nrw sehen wir beim
thema mobbing
da haben wir einfach nur jungs nicht
gemocht und die jungs uns auch nicht das
ist das alte kleine clubs bekommt ihr
locker voll aber reicht das auch für
eine große halle
naja ich momentan nicht auch schon den
heim gespielt da war dann auch schon
1000 2000 menschen also dass also wir
lieben das alles also wir freuen uns
natürlich auch mal dann auf die
sommerfestivals die den sommer kommen
und bis jetzt müssen wirklich einmal
sagen dass wir das dankbar einfach
machen können was wir was wir hier
erleben ist einfach unglaublich also die
ganzen häuser die nach wirklich voll
sind und leute kommen und wollen die
eigene musik das ist schon super und wir
sind dankbar dafür und hoffen dass wir
das noch lange so weitermachen könnten
ihr seid ja durch den wettbewerb 361
grad jetzt super mit youtube vernetzt
deswegen wir würden uns natürlich riesig
freuen wenn wir euch für die lanxess
arena und den video data kriegen
das wäre nicht schlecht das ist das ziel
dann arbeiten wir daran dank ihr euch
jemals dass ihr da wart und viel erfolg
und natur und ja bis dann bleib dran